Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. She held the crucifix high, visible all down the long hall, as she flung defiance at her judges, and her voice rose with a kind of triumph above the voice of the Dean of Peterborough, always higher and clearer than his rising tones, arching over the vehement English prayers, the mysterious dominating invocations of the ancient faith. The Queen's voice held on for a minute after the clergyman had finished. Her words were in English now. She was praying for the people of England,
感谢收听《The Rest is History》。想要获取每周独家番外节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。她高高举起十字架，穿过长廊时清晰可见，她向法官们发出蔑视，她的声音带着一种胜利的喜悦，高过彼得罗夫斯基教长（Dean of Peterborough）的声音，总是比他不断升高的语调更高更清晰，压过激昂的英格兰祈祷文、古老信仰中神秘而主导的祈祷声。在神职人员结束祈祷后，女王的声音又持续了一分钟。她现在用英语祈祷。她在为英格兰人民祈祷，
and for the soul of her royal cousin Elizabeth, she was forgiving all her enemies. Then for a moment her ladies were busy about her. The black velvet gown fell below her knees, revealing underbodies and petticoat of crimson silk. And she stepped forward suddenly, shockingly, in the colour of martyrdom, blood red from top to toe against the sombre background. Quietly she knelt and bowed herself low over the little chopping block. In manus tuas domine, and they heard twice the dull chunk of the axe. There was one more ceremony to accomplish.
并为她的王室表亲伊丽莎白的灵魂祈祷，她原谅了所有的敌人。接着，她的侍女们忙碌了一阵。黑色的天鹅绒长袍落到膝盖以下，露出了红丝绸的紧身衣和衬裙。然后她突然跨前一步，令人震惊地穿上了殉道者的颜色，从头到脚一片血红，与阴暗的背景形成了鲜明对照。她平静地跪下，深深地俯身在那个小断头台上。主啊，交在你的手中（In manus tuas domine），人们听到了两次沉闷的斧头砍击声。还有一个仪式要完成。
The executioner must exhibit the head and speak the customary words. The masked black figure stooped and rose, crying in a loud voice, long live the queen. But all he held in his hand that had belonged to the rival queen of hearts was a kerchief and pinned to it an elaborate auburn wig. Rolled nearer the edge of the platform, shrunken and withered and gray with a sparse silver stubble on the small shiny skull, was the head of the martyr. Mary Stuart had always known how to embarrass her enemies.
刽子手必须展示头颅并说出惯常的话。那个戴着面具的黑色身影弯腰起身，大声喊道，女王万岁。但他手里拿的、属于那位红心女王情敌的东西，却只有一块手帕和别在上面的一顶精致红褐色假发。滚到平台边缘附近的是那个殉道者的头颅，它已经萎缩、干瘪、灰白，光溜溜的小头骨上稀疏地长着银色的短髭。玛丽·斯图亚特一直都知道如何让她的敌人感到难堪。
So that was the American historian Garrett Mattingly in 1950, and he was writing about the execution of Mary Stuart. Mary Queen of Scots of Fotheringay Castle on the 8th of February 1587. Tom Holland, it is one of the most dramatic, one of the most celebrated moments in British history. Iconic because Mary is a bit of an icon isn't she? She's a fashion icon. She is. She's famously beautiful and stylish and well-dressed and all of these kinds of things. And also loads of history about men. Yeah. But now we're absolutely hitting the jackpot. So I would say Mary Queen of Scots is probably the most celebrated
那是美国历史学家加勒特·马丁利（Garrett Mattingly）在1950年的著作，他当时写的是关于玛丽·斯图亚特的处决。苏格兰女王玛丽于1587年2月8日在弗瑟林海城堡（Fotheringay Castle）被处决。汤姆·霍兰，这是英国历史上最戏剧性、最著名的时刻之一。堪称标志性，因为玛丽本身就是一个偶像，不是吗？她是一个时尚偶像。的确如此。她以美貌、时尚、会穿搭以及诸如此类的特质而闻名。而且还有很多关于男人的历史。是的。但现在我们真的是中头奖了。所以我想说玛丽·斯图亚特可能是最著名的
Scot who's ever lived and she celebrated because she is a byword for glamour and romance and tragedy which seems to be what people like in Scottish history. So I guess Bonnie Prince Charlie would perhaps be her only rival, who's also glamorous, romantic and tragic. The story of Mary Queen of Scots is extraordinary. So she becomes the Queen of Scots when she's only one week old. She then goes to France and as a teenager, she briefly rules as Queen of France. And then when she's 19, she comes back to Scotland,
有史以来最伟大的苏格兰人，她之所以出名，是因为她是迷人、浪漫和悲剧的代名词，这似乎正是人们在苏格兰历史中所喜爱的。所以我想邦妮·查理王子（Bonnie Prince Charlie）或许是她唯一的对手，他也同样迷人、浪漫且充满悲剧色彩。苏格兰女王玛丽的故事非同寻常。她在一周大的时候就成了苏格兰女王。然后她去了法国，十几岁时曾短暂担任法兰西女王。接着在19岁时，她回到了苏格兰，
a country that she barely remembers. And she has this incredibly convulsive and ultimately calamitous reign, which is marked by plots and rebellions and two disastrous marriages and two very notorious murders. And as a result, mystery and controversy completely shadows her. So there are all kinds of questions that people are always debating. Was she an adulteress?
一个她几乎没有记忆的国家。她经历了极其动荡最终又充满灾难的统治，其特点是阴谋、叛乱、两段灾难性的婚姻以及两起非常声名狼藉的谋杀案。因此，神秘感和争议完全笼罩着她。所以人们总是在争论各种各样的问题。她是一个通奸者吗？
Was she a murderess? Was she a victim of rape? And she's a very polarizing figure and she always has been. So to her admirers of whom there are lots, she's the archetype of a heroine brought low by duplicitous and brutal men. So she was a figure of romance and now a kind of feminist heroine. But there are lots of people who think she's a complete waste of space, useless, a traitor, conniving, an inept at conniving. So that's even worse than conniving, right? Yeah. I mean, she ends up deposed. You know, that's pretty much the marker of being a failure
她是一个谋杀犯吗？她是一个强奸受害者吗？她是一个非常两极分化的历史人物，而且一直都是。因此，对她的崇拜者（数量众多）而言，她是因狡诈残暴的男人而陷入绝境的女英雄原型。她曾是浪漫的化身，现在则是一种女权主义英雄。但也有很多人认为她简直是一无是处、毫无用处、是个叛徒、喜欢耍阴谋，而且连耍阴谋都很笨拙。所以这比耍阴谋还要糟糕，对吧？是的。我的意思是，她最终被废黜了。你知道，这基本上就是作为一个统治者
as a ruler. And back in the 16th century, the justification for this was precisely that she was a Jezebel, that she was a kind of monstrous archetype of everything that made women rulers a terrible idea. And today, there are absolutely historians who will say that she's one of the most calamitous rulers in Scottish history. And the doyen of these historians who condemn her as a disastrous queen, who is herself Scottish, Jenny Wormald, wrote a brilliant groundbreaking book on Mary Queen of Scots, and she condemned her as a monarch of little wit and no judgment.
失败的标志。而在16世纪，这样做的正当理由恰恰在于她是一个耶洗ebel（Jezebel），她是一个可怕的怪物原型，代表了所有让女性统治者成为一个糟糕主意的事物。而今天，绝对有历史学家会说她是苏格兰历史上最灾难性的统治者之一。谴责她这位灾难性女王的历史学家中的泰斗、她本人也是苏格兰人的珍妮·沃莫尔德（Jenny Wormald），曾写过一本关于苏格兰女王玛丽的精彩且具有突破性的书，她谴责她是一个“才智甚少、毫无判断力”的君主。
A woman who absolutely brought about her own downfall. And so Dominic, we will be sifting the evidence for this today and over the next five episodes of the series and lots to discuss but important to emphasize you were worried that this was maybe an overly Scottish theme I wouldn't say worried I would say excited you will be relieved to know that this isn't just a Scottish story There's quite a lot of England in it as well and I guess that that's evident from the account of the execution that you read, which we opened this episode with because fathering gay, of course, where she ends up being beheaded is in England. I mean, it's in middle England. It's in Northamptonshire. But what that passage also alluded to is the sense in which in death as throughout her adult life, Mary Queen of
一个亲手招致自己灭亡的女人。所以多米尼克，今天以及本系列接下来的五集里，我们将梳理这方面的证据，有很多内容要讨论，但重要的是要强调——你之前担心这可能是一个过于苏格兰的主题。我不会说担心，我会说我很兴奋。你会欣慰地得知，这不仅仅是一个苏格兰的故事。其中还有相当一部分与英格兰有关，我想从你读的那段关于处决的描述中就能看出来，我们本集就是以它开篇的，因为弗瑟林海（Fotheringay），也就是她最终被斩首的地方，当然是在英格兰。我的意思是，它在英格兰中部。在北安普敦郡（Northamptonshire）。但那段文字还暗指了这样一种感觉：在临死前以及整个成年生活中，苏格兰女王玛丽
Scots is shadowed by a rival Queen and this Queen is her own cousin. In fact, it's the woman who had agreed to her death. And that of course is Elizabeth Tudor, Elizabeth the first. Yes. So Mary was the Queen of Scots, Tom Elizabeth was Queen of England. Mary was a Catholic. Elizabeth was a Protestant. And Mary, of course, was married three times but Elizabeth was the Virgin Queen married to her people and to her country and here's the thing we always think of them as the sort of supreme arch rivals but they never actually met they never
一直被一位敌对女王所阴魂不散，而这位女王就是她自己的表姐。事实上，正是那个同意处死她的人。那当然就是都铎王朝的伊丽莎白，伊丽莎白一世。是的。所以玛丽是苏格兰女王，汤姆，伊丽莎白是英格兰女王。玛丽是天主教徒。伊丽莎白是新教徒。玛丽结过三次婚，而伊丽莎白则是童贞女王，嫁给了她的人民和国家。这就是问题所在，我们总是把他们看作那种终极死敌，但他们实际上从未谋面，他们甚至从未
even were in the same building at the same time. No and I think that people ever since have felt that this was a slightly wasted opportunity and that in so many fictional treatments of Mary Queen of Scots, she's always meeting up with Elizabeth I. So there was Schiller in Germany, wrote a famous play about it. Donizetti wrote an opera again where Mary and Elizabeth meet up. And I suppose the most recent example is the 2018 film starring Saoirse Ronan as Mary Queen of Scots. And actually I have next to me and I will hold it up for the benefit of those on YouTube. It's this titanic definitive biography of Mary by John Guy, which came out about 20 years ago.
在同一时间出现在同一栋建筑里。没有。我想从那以后人们一直觉得这是一个有点浪费的机会，在许多关于苏格兰女王玛丽的虚构作品中，她总是与伊丽莎白一世见面。比如德国的席勒（Schiller）就写过一出著名的戏剧。多尼采蒂（Donizetti）也写过一部歌剧，其中玛丽和伊丽莎白相遇了。我想最近的一个例子就是2018年由西尔莎·罗南（Saoirse Ronan）主演的电影《苏格兰女王玛丽》。事实上，我身边就有一本，为了YouTube观众的福利，我要把它举起来。这是约翰·盖伊（John Guy）撰写的关于玛丽的这部划时代的权威传记，大约在20年前出版。
And it's been retitled for the purposes of the film. And on the cover you get Saoirse Ronan as Mary Queen of Scots, but you also get Margot Robbie as Elizabeth the first. And the subtitle is two Queens, one future. Yeah. So that sense that to write about Mary immediately means that you have to write about Elizabeth is really, really powerful and part of the story that we'll be telling. But it's not just an English or Scottish story.
为了电影的需要，它被重新命名了。封面上不仅有饰演苏格兰女王玛丽的西尔莎·罗南，还有饰演伊丽莎白一世的玛格特·罗比（Margot Robbie）。副标题是“双王争霸，一个未来”（Two Queens, One Future）。因此，这种认为“要写玛丽就必须得写伊丽莎白”的感觉非常非常强烈，这也是我们将要讲述的故事的一部分。但这不仅仅是一个英格兰或苏格兰的故事。
It's also a European story, right? Because as you've pointed out, the book that we read from in the beginning, the Garrett Mattingly book is actually a book about the defeat of the Spanish Armada. So Spain and France are involved in this story too. Yeah, so actually that account that you read, it's the first chapter in Mattingly's account of the Spanish Armada. He frames it as the key event that results in Philip II of Spain launching his doomed attempt to conquer England the following year in 1588. And that reflects the fact that throughout her life, Mary was a figure of absolutely European significance and not just for Spain, but even more for France. So although she was the Queen of Scots, actually, I think the kingdom that she loved
它也是一个欧洲的故事，对吧？因为正如你所指出的，我们一开始读的那本书，加勒特·马丁利的那本书，实际上是一本关于西班牙无敌舰队惨败的书。所以西班牙和法国也卷入了禁忌的故事中。是的，实际上你读的那段记载，是马丁利关于西班牙无敌舰队叙述的第一章。他将其视为导致次年（1588年）西班牙国王腓力二世（Philip II）发动注定失败的征服英格兰企图的关键事件。这反映了一个事实：玛丽一生中都是一个具有绝对欧洲意义的人物，不仅对西班牙如此，对法国更是如此。所以尽管她是苏格兰女王，但实际上，我认为她最热爱的王国，
best, the place probably where she felt most at home was France. So like, actually very like Theo, her father was Scottish, but her mother was French. And she goes to, Theo just briefly flashed in and out there. She goes to France when she's very young, she gets educated there, she grows up there, that's where she first marries and becomes a queen. And I think there's a sense in which all through her subsequent life she's a little bit homesick for it. And so perhaps the great irony of her reign and the key to understanding her ultimate tragedy is that the preference of this most famous of all Scots wasn't actually for Scotland at all. Her heart was probably French. Enough preamble, let's get right into the story. So she is born in Linlithgow, west of Edinburgh,
她最感到宾至如归的地方可能是法国。所以，这实际上很像西奥（Theo），她的父亲是苏格兰人，但她的母亲是法国人。她去……西奥刚刚一闪而过。她很小的时候就去了法国，在那里接受教育，在那里长大，那是她第一次结婚并成为女王的地方。我想在某种程度上，在她随后的整个生命中，她都有点对那里魂牵梦萦。所以或许她统治的最大讽刺以及理解她最终悲剧的关键在于，这位所有苏格兰人中最著名的人，其偏爱其实根本不是苏格兰。她的心可能属于法国。废话少说，让我们直接切入正题。她出生在爱丁堡以西的林利思戈（Linlithgow），
one of the great palaces of Scotland on the 8th of December, 1542. So set the scene for us a little bit, Tom. It's perishingly cold, even by the standards of Scotland in winter. So the Tweed, which is the fast flowing river on which I have my Scottish estate and which marked the frontier between Scotland and England, had completely frozen over, which anyone who
这是苏格兰伟大的宫殿之一，时间是1542年12月8日。汤姆，给我们简单介绍一下当时的场景吧。天冷得刺骨，即使以苏格兰冬天的标准来看也是如此。因此，特威德河（Tweed）——那条我拥有苏格兰庄园的湍急河流，也是苏格兰和英格兰的边界——已经完全结冰了，对于任何
knows the Tweed, I mean, it's an extraordinary thing. But despite these perishing conditions, it hasn't stopped the Scots and the English from fighting one another, which for generations after generation, they're always at it. And this is why Mary's father, who is James V, he's 30 years old, he's the King of Scotland, that's why he's not present at Llynlithgow for her birth. And the reason for this is that two weeks earlier, he'd been fighting the English on the western border of Scotland, and he had suffered a humiliating defeat, Solway Moss in Cumberland in England.
了解特威德河的人来说，我的意思是，这是一件非同寻常的事。但尽管环境如此严寒，却并没有阻止苏格兰人和英格兰人互相厮杀，一代又一代，他们总是打个不停。这就是为什么玛丽的父亲詹姆斯五世（James V）——他当时30岁，是苏格兰国王——没有出席在林利思戈举行的玛丽出生仪式的原因。原因在于，两周前他一直在苏格兰西部边境与英格兰人作战，并在英格兰坎伯兰郡（Cumberland）的索尔韦莫斯（Solway Moss）遭受了一场羞辱性的惨败。
He'd managed to escape the battlefield, he'd ridden back, he'd stopped by at Linlithgow where his wife had been entering her confinement, but he hadn't stayed there. Basically, I think because he was kind of too depressed and miserable at his defeat, he felt he had lots to organize. So he went to Edinburgh. In Edinburgh, he felt, oh, I'm just too depressed. And so he went on to a hunting lodge at Falkland and basically he seems to have gone there to commune with his sense of failure, I think. And he basically goes to bed.
他设法逃离了战场，骑马返回，并在林利思戈他的妻子正在待产的地方驻足，但他并没有留在那里。基本上，我想是因为他因战败而感到过于沮丧和痛苦，他觉得自己有很多事情要安排。所以他去了爱丁堡。在爱丁堡，他觉得，哦，我太沮丧了。于是他去了福克兰（Falkland）的一个狩猎小屋，基本上他去那里似乎是为了沉浸在自己的失败感中。然后他就上床睡觉了。
He's very depressed. He's also pox ridden. Okay. He's a great one for the ladies and is absolutely right. Ridden with syphilis. And while he's in bed, he has brought the news that his wife has given birth and it's a daughter. And this plunges him even deeper into misery. Yeah, gutting.
他非常沮丧。而且他还满身花柳病。好吧。他是个出了名的风流人物，确实如此。梅毒缠身。当他躺在床上时，有人带来消息说他的妻子生了，是个女儿。这让他陷入了更深的痛苦之中。是的，太令人沮丧了。
Well, over the course of his life, as we will see, he's fathered a lot of bastard sons, but he has no legitimate male heir. And he'd really been hoping for that. So having a daughter is a huge disappointment to him. Meanwhile, back in Lithgow, the newborn daughter and her mother are doing very well. And this is because a Scottish palace in the mid-16th century is actually an incredibly civilized place to be. Really? Yeah, it's great. It's hung with magnificent tapestries to provide insulation.
好吧，正如我们所看到的，在他的一生中，他生了很多私生子，但他没有合法的男性继承人。他 realmente 一直在期盼这一点。所以生个女儿对他来说是个巨大的失望。与此同时，在林利思戈，刚出生的女儿和她的母亲状况非常好。这是因为16世纪中叶的苏格兰宫殿实际上是一个极其文明的地方。真的吗？是的，太棒了。里面挂着华丽的挂毯以提供隔热。
It's got the cutting edge glazed windows, you know, tremendous glaziers on hand. It's very, very sophisticated. And in the opinion of Mary's mother, the palace at Linlithgow is equal of any chateau to be found in France. She would know. Absolutely, Dominic, because she herself is French. So she's Mary of Guise. She's from a noble family in France, right? And she's famously beautiful and smart, cunning, all of these kinds of things.
它拥有最先进的玻璃窗，你知道，手头有顶尖的玻璃工匠，非常非常精致。在玛丽的母亲看来，林利思戈的宫殿不亚于法国的任何一座城堡。她自然是懂行的。绝对的，多米尼克，因为她本人就是法国人。所以她是吉斯的玛丽（Mary of Guise）。她来自法国的一个贵族家庭，对吧？她以美貌、聪明、狡猾以及诸如此类的特质而闻名。
And I mean, no son. I mean, we're in the same century as Henry VIII and all his carry on. So no son is, you know, always a bad thing. But on the other hand, at least James has an heir of a kind. And you say she's of a noble family. I mean, the Guise are the most influential and domineering noble family in France. And as we will see, they have essentially their eyes on the throne. So she's a very formidable person in her own right. And her marriage
而且，没有儿子。我的意思是，我们正处于与亨利八世（Henry VIII）以及他那些折腾事同一世纪。所以没有儿子，你知道，总归是一件坏事。但从好的方面来看，至少詹姆斯还有某种意义上的继承人。你刚才说她出身贵族家庭。我的意思是，吉斯家族是法国最具影响力和专横的贵族家族。正如我们将看到的，他们的目标基本上是王位。所以她本身就是一个非常令人生畏的人物。她与
to James V, the King of Scotland, it bears witness to what for generations and generations has been the foundation stone of Scotland's foreign policy, which is known by the Scots as the Old Alliance, A-U-L-D, so the Scots spelling, and it is underpinned, I'm afraid to say, by a visceral hostility to England. Which makes complete sense. I mean, strategically, England is the adversary for both countries. The English had fought the French in the Hundred Years War, memories of which are still around obviously in the 16th century. The Scots, so their memories are of their wars of independence, which were 300 years earlier, Robert the Bruce, all of that kind of thing. And actually, both of these have been English defeats, hadn't they? They had, yeah.
苏格兰国王詹姆斯五世的联姻，见证了世世代代以来苏格兰外交政策的基石，被苏格兰人称为“老同盟”（Auld Alliance，A-Uld，即苏格兰语拼写），而我不得不说，它的基础是对英格兰根深蒂固的敌意。这完全说得通。从战略上讲，英格兰是两国共同的对手。英格兰人在百年战争中与法国人交过手，16世纪时人们显然还对这段历史记忆犹新。而苏格兰人，他们的记忆则是关于他们的独立战争，那是300年前的事了，罗伯特·布鲁斯（Robert the Bruce），诸如此类的事情。事实上，这些都是英格兰人的惨败，对吧？的确是，是的。
The English defeat in the Scottish wars of independence had been much more humiliating for the English than their defeat in the hundred years war, basically because Scotland is to England or England is to France, namely less rich, less powerful, fewer reserves of manpower. And this is as true in the time of Mary, the Queen of Scots, as it had been back in the time of Robert Bruce. So the population of England is about three and a half million. Yeah. And Scotland's is well under one million.
英格兰人在苏格兰独立战争中的失败，比他们在百年战争中的失败对英格兰人来说要屈辱得多，主要是因为苏格兰对英格兰而言，就像英格兰对法国而言一样，即更不富裕、力量较弱、人力储备较少。这在苏格兰女王玛丽的时代和在罗伯特·布鲁斯的时代一样真实。所以英格兰的人口大约是三百五十万。是的。而苏格兰的人口则远不到一百万。
The only sizeable town in Scotland at this time is Edinburgh. Even then, I mean, it's only just under 10,000. So London, by way of comparison, is over 60,000. And its entire machinery of government is much less centralized than you get in England or France. And so therefore it's harder to raise and sustain armies in the field. Right.
当时苏格兰唯一初具规模的城镇就是爱丁堡。即便如此，我的意思是，它也仅仅不到一万人。相比之下，伦敦的人口超过了六万。而且它的整个政府机器远没有英格兰或法国那么集中。因此，在战场上征召和维持军队也就更加困难。对的。
And the corollary of that is that generally provided the English aren't distracted by kind of wars in France, they can pretty much be relied upon to defeat the Scots in battle. As they have done in recent years, right? So the 16th century has been pretty good for England in this regard. You mentioned Solway Moss, but they also famously won the Battle of Flockdon. Yep. 1513, a lot of business with pikemen running down into bogs and things.
其必然结果是，通常只要英格兰人不被法国的战争所分散注意力，基本上就可以指望他们在战斗中击败苏格兰人。正如他们近年来所做的那样，对吧？所以16世纪对英格兰来说在这方面相当不错。你提到了索尔韦莫斯（Solway Moss），但他们也因赢得弗洛登战役（Battle of Flodden）而闻名。是的。1513年，长矛手冲进泥潭之类的很多事。
And Mary's grandfather was killed at Flockdon, wasn't he? James the fourth. And a lot of the English people said that he'd been killed by his own side, which is poor from the Scots. Well I think not just English people that Scots thought that too. Right. It's unclear but these rumors certainly play into a kind of opinion that is very common in England and indeed France that Scottish affairs are exceptionally brutal and murderous and that the nobility in Scotland are kind
玛丽的祖父就是在弗洛登阵亡的，不是吗？詹姆斯四世。许多英国人说他是被自己人杀死的，这在苏格兰人看来有点糟糕。嗯，我认为不仅是英国人，苏格兰人也这么想。没错。目前还不清楚，但这些谣言无疑符合英格兰乃至法国普遍存在的一种看法，即苏格兰事务极其残暴和嗜杀，苏格兰的贵族非常非常暴虐和危险。你觉得是这样吗？嗯，我们会看到的。玛丽长大后肯定认为是这样的。到头来，她会这样评价苏格兰人：众所周知，这是一个内部派系林立、对统治者的派系斗争不亚于欧洲任何其他国家的民族。我想她可以回首她的祖先——那些曾坐在她之前的王位上的人——并发现大量证据来支持这一点。所以玛丽是一个斯图亚特（Stuart）。这个名字来源于她的一位祖先所担任的职务，他曾是苏格兰的大总管（High Steward），然后他娶了罗伯特·布鲁斯的女儿，一个名叫玛乔里（Marjorie）的女人，我认为这对于苏格兰女王来说是一个不太可能的名字，并由此创立了斯图亚特王朝。确实很少有斯图亚特国王是死在床上的。有很多人死于与英国人的战斗中，但也有另一个在沿下水道被追捕时被刺杀，还有一个在与自己儿子的战斗中阵亡，事实上，杀死自己父亲的那个儿子就是后来成为詹姆斯四世的人，也就是死在弗洛登的那个人。所以我认为有一种普遍的看法，即成为
of very, very thuggish and dangerous. Do you think that's true? Well we'll see. Mary certainly grows up to think it's true. In due course, she would say of the Scots that they are, as is known, a people as factious amongst themselves and as factious towards their ruler as any other nation in Europe. And I guess that she could look back at her forebears, those who had sat on the throne before her, and found plenty of evidence to support this. So Mary is a steward. The name steward derives from the position held by one of
非常、非常暴虐和危险。你觉得是真的吗？嗯，我们会看到的。玛丽长大后确实认为这是真的。后来，她会这样评价苏格兰人：众所周知，他们是一个内部派系林立、对统治者也同样派系林立的民族，在欧洲其他国家中也是如此。我想她可以回顾自己的祖先，那些曾坐在她之前的王位上的人，并能找到大量证据来支持这一点。所以玛丽是一位斯图亚特。斯图亚特这个名字源于某人所担任的职位
her ancestors who'd been a high steward of Scotland and he had then married the daughter of Robert Bruce, a woman called Marjorie, which I think is an improbable name for Scottish Queen, and thereby founded the Stuart dynasty. And it's true that very few of the Stuart kings kind of die in their beds. So there are lots who die in battle against the English, but there's another who gets assassinated while being pursued down a sewer, another gets killed in battle fighting his own son, and actually the son who kills his own father is the guy who goes on to become James the fourth, the one who dies at Flawdon. So I think there is a general sense that to be
一个苏格兰君主是一件危险的事情。我想这就是为什么詹姆斯对得到一个女儿而不是儿子的消息感到特别沮丧，因为他担心王位上有一个女性，就其本质而言，不仅对苏格兰，而且对他的血脉、他的政权来说都是一种威胁。这里有一句精彩的话，不是吗？恶魔随它去吧。它将以开始的方式结束。
a Scottish monarch is a dangerous thing. And this, I think, is why James is particularly depressed at the news that he's been given a daughter rather than a son, because he's worried that to have a woman on the throne will, by its very nature, be threatening, not just for Scotland, but more specifically for his own line, his own regime. Here's this brilliant line, doesn't he? The devil go with it. It will end as it began.
它始于一个女人，也必将终于一个女人。这到底是怎么回事？是的，它有点被意译为：因一个女孩而兴，也因一个女孩而亡。换句话说，斯图亚特家族通过罗伯特·布鲁斯的女儿玛乔里继承了王位，而到了玛丽·斯图亚特，这一切将宣告结束。所以他非常沮丧。他病情越来越重，然后就死了。根据记录细节的人的说法，他在一片惊人的呕吐物中去世了。
It came from a woman and it will end in a woman. What's all that about? Yeah, it's kind of paraphrased, it came with a lass and it will pass with a lass. So in other words, the Stuarts inherited the throne via Margaery, the daughter of Robert Bruce and with Mary Stuart, it will finish. And so he's very depressed. He gets worse and worse and then he dies. And we're told by someone who records the details that he died amid a marvelous vomit.
太可怕了。这距离玛丽出生正好一周。所以她现在是苏格兰女王，而她才刚出生一周。对的。很明显，如果那些被外国人、而且看起来也包括詹姆斯五世本人所强烈持有的关于苏格兰野蛮和落后的刻板印象是真实的，那么你就会认为斯图亚特家族注定要灭亡。
So I'm horrid. And so this is one week after Mary has been born. And so she's now the Queen of Scotland and she is one week old. Right. And obviously, if the stereotypes, which very strongly held by foreigners, but also it would seem by James V himself, if the stereotypes of Scottish savagery and backwardness are true, then you would think that the Stuarts are doomed.
你知道，王位上坐着一个一周大的女婴，这看起来并不妙。更具威胁性的是，现场有几位贵族自己也对王位提出了可能的诉求，而且对苏格兰更具威胁的是，他们绝对在互相提防。好吧。
You know, a one week old baby girl on the throne, it doesn't look promising. And even more threatening is the fact that there are a couple of noblemen on the scene who themselves have a possible claim to the throne, and who even more threateningly for Scotland absolutely test each other. Okay.
每个人基本上都叫詹姆斯。其中之一是詹姆斯·汉密尔顿（James Hamilton），他是阿伦伯爵（Earl of Arran），他是詹姆斯二世女儿的孙子。这要追溯到好几代以前，但他现在是法定继承人。所以如果玛丽死了，他就能得到王位。没错。他很有心计，但也很滑头，非常非常反复无常。而吉斯的玛丽，苏格兰女王玛丽的母亲鄙视他。
Everybody basically is called James. So one of these is James Hamilton, he is the Earl of Aaron and he is the grandson of the daughter of James the second. So that's going quite a few generations back, but he is now the heir apparent. So if Mary dies, he gets the throne. Right. He's very scheming, but he's also very slippery and very, very inconstant. And Mary of Gies, Mary, Queen of Scots mother despises him.
她这样评价他：“他是一个单纯而又世界上最反复无常的人，他今天决定的事情，明天就会改变。”所以你根本捉摸不透他。好吧。那另一个家伙呢？他叫马修（Matthew），马修·斯图亚特，他是伦诺克斯伯爵（Earl of Lennox）。和阿伦伯爵一样，他是詹姆斯二世女儿的孙子，但他的排名在阿伦之后，因为他的继承权来自女性血脉而非男性血脉。
And she says of him that he was a simple and the most inconstant man in the world for whatever he determineth today, he changes tomorrow. So you can't pin him down. Okay. And the other Blake? So he is called Matthew, Matthew Stewart, and he's the Earl of Lennox. And like the Earl of Arran, he's a grandson of James II's daughter, but he stands behind Arran in the ranking because his claim derives from a female rather than a male line.
因此，苏格兰继承法的固有性别歧视。对，是的。玛丽出生时，他正在法国流亡，但他显然急于回国，一位崇拜者将他描述为“一个身形魁梧、各部位比例匀称的男子”。这挺不错的。各部位。这挺不错的。潜在地是一个非常令人印象深刻的人物。对。
So the inherent sexism of the Scottish laws of inheritance. Right, yeah. And he is in exile in France at this time when Mary is born, but he's obviously itching to return and he's described by one admirer as having been a strong man of personage well proportioned in all his members. So that's nice. In all his members. That's nice. Potentially a very impressive figure. Right.
所以在理智的世界里，这些人中应该有一个人抢走这个婴儿，把它带到类似于伦敦塔的地方，苏格兰版的某个地方，苏格兰的某个棚屋里，然后闷死她或者用其他方式处理掉，就像塔中王子那样，砰，大功告成。让我们继续，为更幸福的苏格兰建立一个美好的稳定政府。但是不，这群苏格兰人可不干。他们本可以这么做，而且你大概会坚决认为他们这么做是对的。但实际上这一切根本没有发生。这是因为实际上苏格兰的政治稳定性，我认为，比国外的负面看法所允许的要高得多。这方面的衡量标准是，自1437年以来——也就是玛丽出生前一个多世纪——连续四位国王作为儿童登上苏格兰王位，他们所有人都熬过了未成年期，并且都长大成为了非常强大和令人生畏的统治者。原因在于，实际上苏格兰君主制拥有一些并不显而易见的优势，我认为，对于伦敦或巴黎的冷嘲热讽者来说是这样的。其中一个优势是，实际上贵族并没有像15th世纪英格兰陷入玫瑰战争时表现得那样野蛮。正如你所提到的，塔里的王子最终被谋杀。苏格兰没有与之相当的事情。我们提到的珍妮·沃莫尔德，这位中世纪晚期和16世纪苏格兰的伟大历史学家，
So in a sane world, one of these men would have got the baby, taken it to some equivalent to the Tower of London, Scottish equivalent, some shack in Scotland and smothered or otherwise dealt with her, princess in the tower style, bang, job done. Let's get on and have a nice stable government for a happier Scotland. But no, forage from the Scots. They could have done it and they would have been right to do it, I guess, would be definitely your take on it. But actually this doesn't happen at all. And this is because actually Scotland is much more politically stable, I think, than the negative perspective abroad allowed. And the measure of this is that since 1437, so that's more than a century before Mary's
所以在理智的世界里，其中一个人本该得到这个婴儿，把它带到类似于伦敦塔的地方——苏格兰的对应机构，苏格兰的某个简陋棚屋——然后将其闷死或以其他方式处理掉，就像塔中的公主那样，砰，大功告成。让我们继续前进，为一个更幸福的苏格兰建立一个稳定美好的政府。但并没有，苏格兰人对此无动于衷。他们本可以这么做，而且他们这么做是对的，我想这绝对是你的看法。但事实上这根本没有发生。这是因为实际上苏格兰在政治上要稳定得多，我认为，这比国外的消极看法所认为的要稳定。而这的衡量标准是，自1437年以来，也就是玛丽出生前一个多世纪
birth, four kings in succession had come to the Scottish throne as children and all of them had survived their minority and all of them had grown up to become very powerful and intimidating rulers. And the reason for this is that actually the Scottish monarchy has a number of advantages that aren't immediately apparent, I think, to, you know, sneer us in London or Paris. And one of these advantages is that actually the aristocracy are not as feral as, say, the English aristocracy had shown themselves to be in the 15th century when England had collapsed into the Wars of the Roses. And as you mentioned, the princes and the tower end up being murdered. There's no equivalent of that in Scotland. And Jenny Wormald, who we mentioned, the great historian of late medieval and 16th century Scotland,
她对苏格兰女王玛丽持批评态度，但她对苏格兰所具备的那种本质稳定性的品质有着极高的见解。她写道：“证据表明，权贵们无限倾向于强有力的皇家统治，而不是缺乏统治。”所以他们并不是在寻求推翻国王。本质上，他们希望一个国王长大并提供权威的统治，因为这对苏格兰更好。是的。他们这么做部分是因为他们害怕
who's very down on Mary, Queen of Scots, she's brilliant on this kind of quality of essential stability that Scotland has. And she writes, the evidence is that the magnates infinitely preferred strong royal rule to lack of it. So they're not looking to overthrow kings. Essentially they want a king to grow up and provide authoritative rule because that's better for Scotland. Yeah. And they're doing that partly because they're frightened of
英格兰人，还是说他们不害怕英格兰人？我认为他们时刻意识到南部边境的英格兰威胁。他们非常清楚，在正面交锋中，英格兰人可能会获胜；但他们也清楚，只要苏格兰有一个强大、稳定的国家，英格兰人就永远无法征服苏格兰。高地尤其可以说是固若金汤。你知道，不仅仅是英格兰人未能征服苏格兰，高地尤其是坚不可摧的。不仅仅是英格兰人未能征服苏格兰，罗马人以前也失败过。只是苏格兰是一个非常非常难以征服的国家。因此，英格兰人就像一阵潮水，
the English or they're not frightened of the English. I think they are constantly aware of the English threat on their southern border. They're well aware that in pitch battle, the English are probably going to win, but they're also aware that as long as there is a strong, stable state in Scotland, the English will never be able to conquer Scotland. The Highlands in particular are effectively impregnable. You know, it's not just the English who failed to conquer Scotland. The Highlands in particular are effectively impregnable. It's not just the English who failed to conquer Scotland, the Romans had failed earlier. It's just Scotland is a very, very difficult country to subdue. And so as a result, the English are kind of like a tide,
他们不断涌入，但几乎注定要退回去。这就是为什么自从爱德华一世（Edward I）试图征服苏格兰而爱德华二世（Edward II）在班诺克本（Bannockburn）战败以来，这只是一连串从未得到解决的无休止的战争和争吵。苏格兰人无法阻止英格兰人进攻，但英格兰人也无法征服苏格兰人。所以你就会遇到这种长达三个世纪的僵局。苏格兰人能够击退英格兰人的原因之一是，
they're constantly flowing in, but they're almost bound to flow back out again. And this is why ever since Edward I tried to conquer Scotland and Edward II had then been defeated at Bannockburn, it's just a relentless sequence of wars and squabbles that are never resolved. The Scots can't stop the English attacking, but the English can't subdue the Scots. And so you just have this kind of three centuries long stalemate. One of the reasons that the Scots are able to see the English off is that
实际上在地缘政治方面，他们的条件相当不错。所以如果你想想法国，法国有英格兰人要对付，但他们也有西班牙人，他们在意大利边境有麻烦。他们在意大利打过仗，对。是的，他们有意大利，有低地国家，他们在莱茵河沿岸有潜在的问题。所以他们几乎在每个角落都有敌人。而英格兰人则被夹在法国和苏格兰之间。因此，每当英格兰人去攻打法国时，正如莎士比亚所说，那个鼬鼠般的苏格兰人就会直奔英格兰北部。
actually in kind of geopolitical terms, they're quite well set. So if you think of France, France has the English to deal with, but they've also got the Spanish, they've got problems on the Italian frontier. They've been fighting in Italy, yeah. Yeah, they've got Italy, they've got the low countries, they've got problems potentially along the Rhine. So they have enemies on almost every corner. The English are sandwiched between France and Scotland. So whenever the English go and attack France, as Shakespeare puts it, the weasel Scott, darts out down into Northern England.
苏格兰人只有一个天然的敌人，那就是英格兰。这就是为什么它实际上不需要像英格兰和法国那样，在百年战争期间发展出集中的官僚机构。他们不需要过多的金钱或人力，因为他们要战斗的唯一领域就是构成英格兰和法国之间分界线的那个非常狭窄的边境。因此，斯图亚特王朝筹集的税款可以花在华丽的船只或大炮上，他们热爱华丽的船只。他们喜欢巨大的加农炮，但他们仍然有足够的资金花在建造像林利思戈那样辉煌的宫殿上。这就是为什么你有精美的玻璃窗和挂毯之类的东西。这是因为苏格兰君主制有富余的资金。基本上，詹姆斯五世是建造苏格兰版城堡的大师。他可以享受法式风格的室内装饰，而且成本极低。正因为如此，苏格兰人自己并不觉得自己是边缘野蛮人。苏格兰君主当然也不这么认为。他们不认为自己是偏远、孤立或落后的。
The Scots only have the one natural enemy and that's England. And this is one of the reasons why it doesn't actually need the centralized bureaucracy that had developed in England and France, say, over the course of the Hundred Years War. They don't need excessive amounts of money or men because the only sphere where they're going to be fighting is that very narrow border that constitutes the line between England and France. And so such taxes as they raise, the Stuarts can blow it on fancy ships or guns and they love a fancy ship. They love a massive cannon, but they can still have enough to then spend it on building glorious
苏格兰唯一的天然敌人就是英格兰。这也是为什么它其实不需要在英法百年战争期间在英格兰和法国发展起来的那种中央集权官僚体制的原因。他们不需要过多的金钱或人手，因为他们唯一要战斗的领域就是构成英格兰和法国之间分界线的那个非常狭窄的边境。因此，斯图亚特王朝筹集到的那些税款，可以花在华丽的船只或大炮上，他们确实喜欢华丽的船只。他们喜欢巨大的大农，但他们仍然有足够的资金把它花在建造辉煌的
palaces like at Linlithgow. This is why you have the wonderful glazing and the tapestries and stuff. It's because the Scottish monarchy has money to spare. Basically, James V is a great builder of kind of the Scottish equivalent of Chateau. He can enjoy French style interior decoration, but massively on the cheap. And because of this, the Scots themselves do not feel that they're peripheral barbarians. And Scots monarchs certainly don't think that. They don't see themselves as being remote or isolated or backwards.
他们绝对认为自己与英格兰国王或法国国王不相上下。这就是为什么我认为，尽管让一个一周大的女婴坐在王位上并不是最优选择，但这并不会注定玛丽的毁灭，也不意味着苏格兰注定要分崩离析。好吧，让我们拭目以待，因为你知道，汤姆，这非常乐观。我们在期待苏格兰历史上的一个黄金时代吗？苏格兰女王玛丽的生活会是一片美好吗？休息之后见。欢迎回到《The Rest Is History》。现在，如果你还不是《The Rest Is History》俱乐部的会员，我知道你一直在做什么。你一直在听广告。你可真傻。你应该加入俱乐部，这样就不用听广告了。
They see themselves absolutely as being the peers of the King of England or the King of France. And so that's why I think, although it's not optimal to have a one week old baby girl on the throne, it doesn't doom Mary and it doesn't mean that Scotland is doomed to fall to pieces. Well let's find out because you know Tom that's very optimistic. Are we looking to a golden age of Scottish history? Is Mary Queen of Scots life going to be all sweetness and light? Find out after the break. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. Now, if you're not a member of The Rest Is History Club, I know what you've been doing. You've been listening to the adverts. More fool you. You should join the club and you won't have to listen to them.
但在你听广告的这段时间里，发生了不寻常的景象。九个月过去了，玛丽刚刚在斯特林城堡（Stirling Castle）加冕。汤姆，这里有一个略带不祥之兆的迹象，因为她加冕的日期正是弗洛登战役的周年纪念日。是的，也就是1543年9月9日，弗洛登战役29周年纪念日。苏格兰历史上的大灾难，他们怎么偏偏挑了那个日子？好吧，这在玛丽的敌人看来会被视为一个不祥之兆，
But while you've been listening to the adverts, extraordinary scenes. Nine months have passed and Mary has just been crowned in Stirling Castle. A slightly bad omen here Tom, because she was crowned on the anniversary of the Battle of Flodden. Yes, so the 9th of September 1543, 29 years after the Battle of Flodden. So big disaster in Scottish history, why on earth have they chosen that date? Well it will be seen by Mary's enemies as a bad omen,
但就在你听广告的时候，发生了非同寻常的一幕。九个月过去了，玛丽刚刚在斯特林城堡加冕。汤姆，这里有一个稍微不祥的征兆，因为她是在弗洛登战役纪念日加冕的。是的，也就是1543年9月9日，弗洛登战役二十九周年纪念日。苏格兰历史上的大灾难，为什么偏偏选这一天呢？好吧，这在玛丽的敌人看来将是一个不祥之兆，
but I think you could just as easily see it as a mark of Scottish insouciance. They've already got overflodden, forget it, you know, yeah who cares. As you said she's crowned in Stirling Castle, which has always been viewed as the key to Scotland. Bannockburn is kind of fought in its shadow, it guards the lowest crossing point on the River Forth, and it's pretty much impregnable. So that is one of the reasons why Mary is there. The crown has to be held over the baby Queen's head because obviously it would crush her if it was laid on top of her. And Mary cries and balls and
但我认为你同样可以把它看作是苏格兰人漫不经心的一种表现。他们已经走出了弗洛登的阴影，忘掉它吧，你知道，谁在乎呢。正如你所说，她在斯特林城堡加冕，这里一直被视为苏格兰的关键。班诺克本战役就是在它的阴影下进行的，它守卫着福斯河（River Forth）上最低的渡口，而且几乎是坚不可摧的。所以这就是玛丽在那里的原因之一。王冠必须举在婴儿女王头顶上方，因为如果戴在她头上显然会压垮她。玛丽在整个加冕仪式中一直在哭泣、号啕和大哭，
sobs the whole way through the ceremony which again, bad bad omen people might see as an omen, but you know, very clearly if she's being crowned, she hasn't been murdered. No coronation is going ahead. The country hasn't collapsed into civil war and great news deals of Aaron and Lennox. So the two men who we mentioned in the first half, who both have claims to be her successor, they've been there. So the first one, massive snake. Yeah, always changing his mind.
这再次被人们视为一个不祥的征兆，但很明显，既然她正在加冕，她就没有被谋杀。加冕典礼仍在进行。国家没有陷入内战，阿伦和伦诺克斯的交易也是个好消息。所以在上半场我们提到的那两个对她的继承权都有诉求的人，他们都在场。所以第一个，绝对是个阴险小人。是的，总是改变主意。
The other bloke. Good members. Well proportioned members. Exactly. So Aaron has carried the crown in the coronation procession. Lennox has carried the scepter. If you throw in the sword of state as well, these constitute the honours of Scotland, as they're called, and you can see them to this day in Edinburgh Castle. Attentive listeners may remember that
另一个家伙。身材匀称的家伙。没错。所以阿伦在加冕游行中抬着王冠。伦诺克斯抬着权杖。如果你再加上象征国家的宝剑，这些构成了所谓的苏格兰王权信物（Honours of Scotland），直到今天你还可以在爱丁堡城堡看到它们。细心的听众可能还记得
Lennox had been in exile in France, so obviously if he's there in Stirling, he's negotiated his return. So it's good for him, but it's Aaron probably at this point who is ahead because he has won the backing of Scotland's Parliament to serve both as regent and to be nominated as Mary's official heir. So yeah, watch out for him. If he had a Richard the third vibe, we know what would happen. Yeah. But we will see in one sense as a kind of surprising degree of political stability. These two worlds are kind of, you know, they're eyeballing each other, but they're not trying to kill Mary, they're not in open opposition to one another. But the state of Scotland is unsettled even so, and this is due not so much to the rivalry between Aaron and Lennox, but to a much more formidable and enduring
伦诺克斯曾在法国流亡，所以显然如果他出现在斯特林，他已经通过谈判回国了。这对他来说是好事，但此时阿伦可能处于领先地位，因为他赢得了苏格兰议会的支持，既担任摄政王，又被指定为玛丽的官方继承人。所以，是的，小心他。如果他有理查三世（Richard III）的气场，我们就知道会发生什么了。是的。但我们将从某种意义上看到一种惊人的政治稳定程度。这两个世界有点，你知道，他们在互相打量，但他们没有试图杀死玛丽，他们也没有公开反对彼此。即便如此，苏格兰的局势仍然动荡不安，这与其说是由于阿伦和伦诺克斯之间的竞争，不如说是由于一个更强大、更持久的竞争，即法国和英格兰之间的竞争。所以这两个王国显然都听到了消息。有一个婴儿女孩，他们都在想，哦，你知道，这里有一个机会。现在你可能会认为，法国人会因为老同盟之类的原因与苏格兰达成协议，对吧？而英格兰人则是那种，你知道，老敌人，诸如此类的事情。事情要复杂一些，对吧？所以英格兰人此时实际上正与苏格兰交战，技术上是这样的吗？
rivalry which is that between France and England. So both of those kingdoms, they've obviously heard the news. There's this infant girl and they're both thinking, oh, you know, this opportunity here. Now you would think, wouldn't you, that the French would be the people who would do a deal with Scotland because of the old alliance and all that kind of thing. And the English are kind of the, you know, they're the old enemy and all of that stuff. And it's a little bit more complicated, isn't it? So the English are actually at war with Scotland at this point, technically, is that right?
法国和英格兰之间的竞争。所以这两个王国显然都听到了消息。这里有一个婴儿女孩，他们都在想，哦，你知道，这是一个机会。现在你可能会想，法国人会是那个与苏格兰达成协议的人，因为有老同盟以及诸如此类的东西。而英格兰有点像是，你知道的，他们是老敌人以及所有这些东西。情况要复杂一些，对吧？所以从技术上讲，英格兰此时实际上正在与苏格兰交战，是这样吗？
Yeah, you know, I mean, Mary's father died of a broken heart after being defeated by them. Right. And of course, also, Mary is under the wing of her mother, Mary of Guise, who's very much a French woman. So why is this even an issue? Why the English, even in in play as a possible ally? Doesn't make sense. Because over the decade before Mary is born, something very kind of novel, unexpected, and I think for relations between Scotland, England and France,
是的，你知道，我的意思是，玛丽的父亲在被他们击败后心碎而死。对的。当然，玛丽也在她的母亲——非常法国化的吉斯的玛丽的羽翼之下。所以这怎么会是个问题呢？为什么英格兰人甚至还能作为潜在盟友登场？这说不通。因为在玛丽出生前的十年里，某种非常新颖、出乎意料、而且我认为对于苏格兰、英格兰和法国之间关系而言，
I think for relations between Scotland, England and France, very destabilizing has begun to emerge which is a pro-English faction in Scotland. Absolute scenes, I mean unheard of. So people may wonder how on earth is it that a pro-English faction has grown up in Scotland? And the answer to that is that the storm clouds of the Reformation have been massing not just over Europe, but over Scotland. Because just as has been happening in England at the same time, the country is being shaken by the emergence of a novel and very fast growing heresy in Germany. So we did five episodes on this, the life of Martin Luther, yeah, kind of a father of the Reformation. And his writings had been detected in Scotland as early
对于苏格兰、英格兰和法国之间的关系而言，非常具有破坏性的因素开始出现，那就是苏格兰国内出现了一个亲英派系。绝对的大场面，简直闻所未闻。所以人们可能会好奇，苏格兰怎么会产生一个亲英派系呢？答案是，宗教改革的暴风雨不仅在欧洲上空汇聚，也在苏格兰上空汇聚。因为正如英格兰同时发生的情况一样，这个国家正被德国一种新颖且迅速蔓延的异端邪说的出现而震撼。所以我们为此做了五集节目，关于马丁·路德（Martin Luther）的一生，是的，某种程度上是宗教改革之父。早在
as 1524. So that's only a few years after he nailed up his theses in Bittenberg. And then three years later, so in 1527, there is a report from a concerned Catholic that Luther's writings are circulating widely in Edinburgh and St Andrews. And then the following year in 1528, you get the first martyrdom of a Protestant. And this is a former Catholic priest called Patrick Hamilton. And he's burnt at the stake in St Andrews, which is one of Scotland's three universities at this point, and the oldest and most prestigious. So this is all going on. But surely there's a huge thing. It's not just coming from Germany or from Flanders or other places the tracks are coming from, but the fact that England has been embroiled
1524年，他的著作就在苏格兰被发现了。这距离他在维滕贝格（Wittenberg）贴出他的《九十五条论纲》仅仅几年时间。三年后，也就是1527年，一位担忧的天主教徒报告说，路德的著作正在爱丁堡和圣安德鲁斯（St Andrews）广泛流传。随后的1528年，你迎来了第一位殉道的新教徒。这是一个名叫帕特里克·汉密尔顿（Patrick Hamilton）的前天主教神父。他在圣安德鲁斯被火刑处死，圣安德鲁斯是当时苏格兰三所大学之一，也是历史最悠久、声望最高的大学。所以这一切都在进行中。但这肯定是一件大事。这不仅仅是来自德国、佛兰德斯或其他地方的小册子，而是英格兰也卷入了其中
in the Reformation because of Henry VIII's marital issues, presumably has a massive knock-on effect on Scotland because now all sorts of tracts and ideas can arrive across the very porous Anglo-Scottish border. Yeah, and of course they're written in a form of English, so Scots, which is pretty different from the kind of English that is being written by Protestant reformers in London or Cambridge or whatever. But I mean, it's much easier for Scots to read than say German. And so these pamphlets have an outsize effect on Scottish opinion, as you said. And of course, as you also said, there is the outsize figure of Henry the eighth. And by this point, I mean, he really is outsize. He's, he's very much a person of bulk. Yeah.
由于亨利八世的婚姻问题引发了宗教改革，这据信对苏格兰产生了巨大的连锁反应，因为现在各种小册子和思想能够穿过戒备森严的英苏边境涌入。是的，当然它们是用某种英语形式——也就是低地苏格兰语写成的，这与伦敦或剑桥等地的宗教改革家所写的英语有很大不同。但我的意思是，苏格兰人阅读这种语言比阅读德语要容易得多。正如你所说，这些小册子因此对苏格兰的舆论产生了超乎寻常的影响。当然，正如你刚才所说，还有亨利八世这个庞然大物般的形象。到了这个时候，我的意思是，他真的变得非常庞大。他整个人非常臃肿。是的。
He's got that massive ulcer. Yes. All those injections up his ass and stuff. I mean, it's all, it's all happening. So, so his kind of beady piggy little eyes have lit up at the prospect that the spread of Protestantism in Scotland offers him to make mischief. So actually four months after Mary was born, he'd written to the Earl of Arran, the slippery guy has become the Regent. He proposes a raft of Protestant style reforms. So he says that the Scots should have the Bible freely available in their own language, that tracts opposed to the English Reformation should be cracked down on. So that's kind of pro-Catholic ones. And also he tells the Earl of Arran, you know, get on and dissolve
他身上长了个巨大的溃疡。是的。屁股上塞满了各种药剂之类的。我的意思是，这一切都在发生。所以，当苏格兰新教的传播让他看到了兴风作浪的前景时，他那双小小的、珠子般的、贪婪的眼睛一下子就亮了起来。事实上，在玛丽出生四个月后，他就写信给已经成为摄政王的、狡猾的阿兰伯爵。他提出了一系列新教风格的改革。因此他表示，苏格兰人应该能够自由地阅读他们自己语言的圣经，应该打击那些反对英国宗教改革的小册子。也就是那些亲天主教的小册子。此外，他还告诉阿兰伯爵，你知道的，去解散
the monasteries. It's absolutely brilliant. And he very overtly frames this not as being justified by, you know, the true religion of Protestantism or whatever, but it's brilliant. You'll make so much money. Look how much cash I've got. It's great. Tom, you can fat shame Henry VIII as much as you like, but those are all actually quite good ideas. The Scots would have done well to profit from them. Anyway. You're right, because the Earl of Arran, who is actually quite a devout Catholic, I mean, he's pretty tempted by this. Henry, in his own way, is Catholic as well. Yeah. There's a kind of streak of opportunism there that I think is as evident
修道院吧。这绝对是个绝妙的主意。而且他非常公开地将这一点包装起来，不是说这是由新教的真理或别的什么所证明的，而是——这太棒了。你们会赚大笔钱的。看看我手里有多少现金。这太棒了。汤姆，你可以尽情地对亨利八世进行身材羞辱，但这些实际上都是相当不错的建议。苏格兰人如果能从中获利，那就太好了。不管怎样。你是对的，因为阿兰伯爵实际上是一个相当虔诚的天主教徒，我的意思是，他对此非常心动。亨利以他自己的方式来说也是天主教徒。是的。我认为，苏格兰高层和英国一样，
in the higher reaches of Scotland as in England. And there's a further aspect of Scottish affairs that Henry finds tempting, which is that having a girl as a queen means that she's obviously going to have to be married off. And Henry's heir is a young boy, the male heir that he'd done so much to try and secure. And this boy, Edward, he's going to need a wife. So Henry says to Aaron, why don't we match them up? It would be brilliant. And so in July, 1543, Henry and the Earl of Arran duly sign a treaty in Greenwich, just down the Thames from London. And its provisions from the point of view of Henry VIII are brilliant. So Mary is going to be brought up with English speaking attendance. So not Scott speaking attendance. She'll grow
都存在着一种机会主义的倾向。苏格兰事务中还有另一个让亨利垂涎的方面，那就是作为一个女婴的女王，她显然注定要嫁出去。而亨利的继承人是一个小男孩，也就是他费尽心机才确保下来的男性继承人。这个名叫爱德华的男孩需要一个妻子。于是亨利对阿兰说，我们为什么不把他们凑成一对呢？这将是个绝妙的主意。因此，在1543年7月，亨利与阿兰伯爵在伦敦泰晤士河下游的格林尼治正式签署了一项条约。从亨利八世的角度来看，其中的条款堪称完美。玛丽将由说英语的随从而不是说苏格兰语的随从抚养长大。她将
up with a nice received pronunciation accent. Okay. Then at the age of 10, she'll marry Prince Edward. Their children will rule a United Kingdom of Great Britain. Aaron will commit to pursuing essentially Protestant policies. So all of these are wins for Henry and England. The only concession that Henry grants to the Scots is that Mary's kingdom will continue to be called Scotland and retain its ancient laws and liberties.
在带有标准伦敦腔的口音中长大。好吧。然后，在10岁时，她将嫁给爱德华王子。他们的孩子将统治一个大不列颠联合王国。阿兰将致力于推行实质上的新教政策。因此，所有这些对亨利和英格兰来说都是胜利。亨利对苏格兰人做出的唯一让步是，玛丽的王国将继续被称为苏格兰，并保留其古老的法律和自由。
It'll be a bit of a dual monarchy, I guess. Yeah, that's the plan. Like an Austro-Hungarian empire. So there's a massive road not taken. What a historical what if that is, because if that had happened, the story of the 17th century and thereafter would have been completely different. Why does it not happen when they've done this deal in Greenwich? Because Aaron finds it impossible to take the rest of the country with him.
这大概会变成一个双元君主国吧。是的，这就是计划。就像奥匈帝国一样。所以这里有一个巨大的、未曾走过的道路。这是一个多么具有历史假设意味的选择啊，因为如果那件事发生了，17世纪及以后的历史将会完全不同。既然他们在格林尼治达成了这笔交易，为什么后来没有发生呢？因为阿兰发现根本无法带着全国其他地方的人一起走。
Most people in Scotland do not want to end up as they would see it subordinated to England, even the Protestants. And at this point, most people in Scotland are still very much Catholic, so it's just impossible. But more than that, he has a very, very effective opponent in Scotland in the form of Mary of Guise, the French mother of Mary, Queen of Scots, who is absolutely determined not to let her daughter become a kind of an English queen. And so this is one of the reasons why she's removed Mary to Stirling Castle, which is effectively impregnable. It had been a personal gift from James V to Mary of Guise. So it's her own personal stronghold. This
苏格兰的大多数人并不希望最终落得他们所看到的、从属于英格兰的下场，即使是新教徒也是如此。此时，苏格兰的大多数人仍然是非常坚定的天主教徒，所以这根本不可能。不仅如此，他在苏格兰还有一个非常非常强有力的对手，那就是苏格兰女王玛丽的法国母亲吉斯的玛丽，她坚决不让自己的女儿变成某种意义上的英国女王。这也是她把玛丽转移到实际上坚不可摧的斯特灵城堡的原因之一。那是詹姆斯五世给吉斯的玛丽的个人礼物。所以那是她自己的私人根据地。这
means that Aaron cannot get his hands on the infant queen. I mean, if he had been able to, then maybe history would have been different if Mary had been kind of packed off to London. I mean, who knows what would have happened. But Mary of Guise has her daughter and Stirling is not going to be captured. More than that, of course, Mary of Guise is very effective at playing the rival would be strong men of Scotland. So as well as Aaron, there is Lennox. She drops subtle hints to Lennox that perhaps she might be interested in marrying him. This would be great for Lennox. That might help solidify his claim to the throne. And at the same time, Mary of Gies, very kind of cunning and clever, she's also giving a kind of little hint of
意味着阿兰无法掌控这位婴儿女王。我的意思是，如果他当时能做到这一点，那么如果玛丽被打包送到伦敦的话，历史也许就会不同了。我的意思是，谁知道会发生什么呢。但吉斯的玛丽拥有她的女儿，斯特灵城堡是攻不破的。不仅如此，吉斯的玛丽非常擅长玩弄苏格兰那些潜在的强权人物。除了阿兰之外，还有伦诺克斯。她向伦诺克斯暗示，自己或许对嫁给他感兴趣。这对伦诺克斯来说太棒了。这可能有助于巩固他对王位的声索。与此同时，足智多谋、非常聪明的吉斯的玛丽，也向苏格兰最有权势的贵族之一
her ankle to another of Scotland's most powerful noblemen. There's a guy called Patrick Hepburn, and he is the Earl of Bothwell and he's a very big player. So he, by hereditary right, is the Lord Admiral of Scotland and he's the Sheriff of Edinburgh. So to control both the fleet and the capital, I mean, that's quite something. And his castle is, I mean, I think probably the most sinister, brooding and atmospheric castle in the whole of Britain. It's called the Hermitage. It's right on the borders of England and Scotland. It's in what at the time was the most dangerous area in the whole of Britain. It was called
抛出了橄榄枝。有个叫帕特里克·赫本的家伙，他是博斯韦尔伯爵，一个举足轻重的人物。因此，根据世袭权利，他是苏格兰的海军上将，也是爱丁堡的治安官。既控制了舰队又控制了首都，我的意思是，这可真了不得。而他的城堡，我的意思是，我认为可能是全不列颠最阴森、压抑且极具氛围感的城堡。它被称为“隐士修道院”。它就位于英格兰和苏格兰的边境上。它坐落在当时全不列颠最危险的地区。那里被称为
the debatable lands. It was given over to bandits called Reavers. I don't know if you've ever been to it, Dominic. It's like something out of Game of Thrones. We say that about so much that we talk about, but it really is. If you imagine the kind of terrifying place you would not want to end up, this is the castle, the Hermitage. And so unsurprisingly, with all these attributes, the Earl of Bothwell, he doesn't suffer from self-esteem issues. So Henry VIII's ambassador to Scotland described him as the most vain and insolent man in the world, full of pride and folly. Poor old Aaron, he's up against Lennox, he's up against the Earl of Bothwell and he's up against Mary
“三不管地带”（可辩论之地）。那里被名为“掠夺者”的强盗们占领着。多米尼克，我不知道你有没有去过那里。那感觉就像《权力的游戏》里的场景。我们对谈论的很多东西都这么说，但它确实如此。如果你想象一下那种你绝对不想沦落进去的可怕地方，就是这座“隐士修道院”城堡。因此毫不奇怪，拥有所有这些特质的博斯韦尔伯爵并不缺乏自我感觉。所以亨利八世驻苏格兰的大使形容他是世界上最虚荣、最无礼的人，充满傲慢与愚蠢。可怜的老阿兰，他要对抗伦诺克斯，要对抗博斯韦尔伯爵，还要对抗玛丽
of Gies and basically he finds himself with no option but to reverse ferret. So, you know, he's very changeable. Whatever he determineth today, he changes tomorrow, as Mary of Guise had said of him. And so having signed this treaty with Henry VIII, he gets back to Scotland, discovers nobody's in favour of it, and so he completely rips it up. He abandons the English alliance. He stops pretending to be Protestant, and he submits to attending Mary's coronation alongside Lennox and Mary of Gies. So that's what he's doing, holding the crown over Mary. And this is obviously very, very humiliating for him,
吉斯，基本上他发现自己别无选择，只能出尔反尔。所以，你知道的，他非常多变。正如吉斯的玛丽对他的评价那样：“他今天决定的一切，明天就会改变”。因此，在与亨利八世签署了这项条约后，他回到苏格兰，发现没有人支持它，于是他彻底把它撕毁了。他放弃了同盟关系。他不再假装自己是新教徒，并屈服于同伦诺克斯和吉斯的玛丽一起出席玛丽的加冕礼。所以这就是他在做的，将王冠悬于玛丽头顶。这对他来说显然非常非常羞辱，
but it's also humiliating for Henry VIII in England. Right, and Henry VIII. So Mary of Gies is delighted, but Henry VIII is absolutely furious, isn't he? And actually... Livid. Yeah, he demands vengeance. So what are we 1544, April 1544? He tells one of the Seymours, so Jane Seymour's brother Edward, and he basically says, get into Scotland, put all to fire and sword, burn Edinburgh town. So raised and defaced when you've sacked and gotten what you can of it, as there may
但对英格兰的亨利八世来说同样是一种羞辱。没错，还有亨利八世。因此吉斯的玛丽欣喜若狂，但亨利八世却愤怒至极，对吧？事实上……怒不可遏。是的，他要求复仇。那么我们现在是在什么时候，1544年，1544年4月？他告诉其中一个西摩家族的人，也就是简·西摩的弟弟爱德华，他基本上说道：杀进苏格兰，实行残酷的三光政策，烧毁爱丁堡城。当你们洗劫并掠夺了所有能拿走的东西后，将其夷为平地并面目全非，以便
remain forever a perpetual memory of the vengeance of God for their falsehood and disloyalty. Put all the men and women and children to the sword, do all this, do all that, destroy the villages. He's not messing around. No. So Seymour leads a massive English army into Scotland and what follows is the most brutal war of destruction that the English have ever waged in Scotland. And obviously there have been quite a few brutal wars of destruction. And it goes on for eight years. It outlasts Henry VIII himself. And it was memorably termed by Sir Walter Scott in the early 19th century as the rough wooing. Right. So basically there's this idea that you go and destroy everything in your path and this is somehow
永远留作上帝对他们的虚伪和不忠进行复仇的永恒纪念。将所有的男人、女人和儿童都置于刀剑之下，做所有这些事情，做所有那些事情，摧毁所有的村庄。他可不是在开玩笑。没有。因此西摩率领庞大的英国军队开进苏格兰，随之而来的是英国人在苏格兰发动的最残酷的毁灭战争。显然，此前已经有过相当多的残酷毁灭战争了。这场战争持续了八年。它甚至比亨利八世本人还要长寿。19世纪初，沃尔特·斯科特爵士给它取了一个令人难忘的名字——“粗暴求婚”。对吧。所以基本上有这样一种想法：你前去摧毁你道路上的一切，而这不知怎的
supposed to persuade the Scots to give Mary Queen of Scots to Prince Edward in London. And so on one level, this is obviously self-defeating because it only confirms the majority of Scots in their kind of ancestral loathing for the English. And also, of course, playing into Mary of Guise's hands, really, it only confirms them in their view of France as their natural kind of essential ally. But having said that, I think the most striking thing about the rough wooing, this kind of brutal English campaign against the Scots, isn't that it kind of gives fresh impetus to the kind of traditional Scottish Anglophobia, but what's most amazing, what's most unexpected is that actually not everyone in Scotland is alienated by it. And the reason for that is that there's
应该能够说服苏格兰人将苏格兰女王玛丽交给伦敦的爱德华王子。所以从某种层面来看，这显然是适得其反的，因为它只会让大多数苏格兰人更加坚信他们对英国人世世代代的厌恶。而且，当然，这也正中吉斯的玛丽下怀，实际上，这只会让他们更加确信法国才是他们天然的、核心的同盟。话虽如此，我认为关于“粗暴求婚”（这场针对苏格兰人的残暴英国战役）最引人注目的一点，并不是它为传统苏格兰的反英情绪注入了新的动力，而最令人惊奇、最意想不到的是，实际上并不是苏格兰的每个人都因此而对立。原因在于，
now a constituency of support for the English as co-religionists, as fellow Protestants that actually can survive all the kind of the bloodshed and the slaughter and the ruin and the burning that the English are now inflicting on Scotland. The Reformation has got a sufficient hold on Scottish opinion that ties of religion are coming to seem to some Scots more important than the traditional hatred of the English. But it's also surely that thing that always happens when you have a smaller country and a larger country. There's always going to be a faction who see the opportunities and align themselves with
现在有了一部分支持英国人的政治力量，他们作为同信仰者、作为同为新教徒的人，实际上能够经受住英国现在对苏格兰造成的各种流血、屠杀、废墟和烈火的考验。宗教改革在苏格兰舆论中已经占据了足够的地位，以至于宗教纽带在一些苏格兰人看来，比传统的对英国人的仇恨更加重要。但这也绝对是当一个小国和一个大国并存时总会发生的事情。总会有一派人看到机遇，并与
the big overbearing neighbor just because of the internal dynamics of kind of court politics. There's always ins and outs. So for people who hate the English, there's always mileage to be had, surely, in allying yourself with a very powerful patron across the border. I mean, kind of, but essentially that would be seen by Scots in the centuries since the Wars of Independence as treason. Okay. You know, you would be a traitor for doing that. What has changed with the Reformation is that
这个傲慢的大邻居结盟，仅仅是因为某种宫廷政治的内部动态。总会有各种内幕。所以对于那些痛恨英国人的人来说，与跨越边境的强大赞助人结盟，肯定总是能带来好处的。我的意思是，某种程度上是这样，但在自独立战争以来的几个世纪里，苏格兰人基本上会把这视为叛国。好吧。你知道的，这样做你就是个叛徒。随着宗教改革而改变的是，
there are now Scots who can say, well, my conscience requires me to ally myself with fellow people who have cast off the Whore of Babylon. And that in turn does enable a kind of novel political faction to develop, which sees an alliance with England as something that is preferable to the traditional French alliance, because the French alliance doesn't come without strings either. France is even more of a preponderant power than England. And so it does mean that to a degree the Scots are subordinated. And so there is now scope for kind of pro English and pro French factions actually to be a kind of genuine dynamic in Scottish politics. And that in turn means, you know, if you are a player in Scottish politics, you can kind
现在有一些苏格兰人可以这样说：“好吧，我的良知要求我与那些同样摆脱了巴比伦娼妇的人结盟。”而这反过来确实促成了一种新颖的政治派别的形成，这一派人认为与英国结盟比传统的法兰西同盟更可取，因为法兰西同盟同样附带各种条件。法国甚至是一个比英国更具压倒性的力量。因此，这确实意味着苏格兰人在某种程度上处于从属地位。所以现在确实有空间让亲英和亲法派系真正成为苏格兰政治中的一种真实动力。而这反过来又意味着，如果你是苏格兰政治中的一个玩家，你就可以在它们之间
of switch between them. And I guess the classic example of this is Lennox. Mary of Guise has been kind of saying, maybe I'll marry you, whatever, maybe I will, maybe I won't. But she'd actually been playing him along, she's been playing the field, she's been winking at the Earl of Bothwell as well, and so Lennox realizes this, realizes that Mary of Gies has no intention of marrying him and has a massive strop and openly turns pro-English. He basically yells at Mary of Gies, says you're terrible, you're an absolute slag, I'm off,
来回摇摆。我想典型的例子就是伦诺克斯。吉斯的玛丽一直都在说：“也许我会嫁给你，管他是呢，也许我会，也许我不会。”但她实际上一直在敷衍他，脚踩两只船，同时也对博斯韦尔伯爵暗送秋波。因此伦诺克斯意识到了这一点，意识到吉斯的玛丽根本无意嫁给他，于是大发雷霆，公开转为亲英派。他基本上对吉斯的玛丽大喊大叫，说你太糟糕了，你绝对是个贱人，我要走了，
storms off to England. And when he's there, remember he has a claim to the Scottish throne. He assigns this claim to the Scottish throne, to the English king. Ooh, that's a big decision. It is a big decision. And he is very royally rewarded. So he's given extensive lands in Yorkshire in the north of England, but he's also given the hand of one of Henry VIII's nieces in marriage. And this is potentially, I mean, looking ahead,
怒气冲冲地去了英格兰。当他在那里时，别忘了他对苏格兰王位拥有声索权。他将这个对苏格兰王位的声索权转让给了英国国王。哦，那是个重大的决定。这确实是个重大决定。他得到了丰厚的回报。因此他被授予了英格兰北部约克郡的大片土地，还将亨利八世的一个侄女许配给他作为妻子。从长远来看，这可能是一个
a very momentous development because it means that any children, and perhaps more specifically any sons he has, will not just have Stuart blood in his veins, but the blood of the Tudors as well. And so therefore potentially a claim to the throne of England, as well as Scotland. Right. All of this, of course, well in the future. If you're Mary of Gies, presumably you look at this and you think, Oh, this is terrible. This is a very ominous development.
非常重大的发展，因为这意味着任何孩子，或者更具体地说他可能拥有的任何儿子，不仅身体里流淌着斯图尔特的血液，还将流淌着都铎王朝的血液。因此，他们潜在地拥有了对英格兰以及苏格兰王位的继承权。没错。当然，所有这一切都还在未来。如果你是吉斯的玛丽，你大概会看着这一切并心想：“哦，这太糟糕了。这是一个非常不妙的发展。”
Oh, does she not care? And she thinks it's fine. I mean, she thinks Lennox is, I mean, the kind of peripheral figure who cares. Okay. She's got the rough wooing going on all around outside Stirling Castle. The castle is so secure that she can basically ride it out. So she sits in Stirling Castle with her daughter, Mary, Queen of Scots, even as the countryside is on fire.
哦，难道她不在乎吗？她觉得这没问题。我的意思是，她认为伦诺克斯不过是个无足轻重的小人物，谁在乎呢。好吧。“粗暴求婚”战役就在斯特灵城堡外到处进行着。城堡固若金汤，她基本上可以安然度过。所以她和她的女儿——苏格兰女王玛丽一起坐在斯特灵城堡里，任凭乡间大火熊熊燃烧。
And the brilliant thing from her point of view is that the blame for the rough wooing does not fall on her but on Aaron, who completely gets the blame for it. And she's able to take advantage of this to leverage her own position of authority within Scotland. So Aaron is forced to accept her presence alongside him in the Privy Council and in Parliament. And this now means that Mary of Gies doesn't have to operate in the traditional way that women do in Scotland, kind of behind the scenes. She has her hands directly on the levers of power, and so she's therefore in pole position to push her dream policy, which is to marry her daughter directly into the French royal family. And this is obviously a great way of renewing the old alliance between Scotland and France and potentially subordinate Scotland permanently to French interests.
从她的角度来看，最妙的事情在于，“粗暴求婚”的罪名并没有落在她头上，而是落在了阿兰头上，完全由他来背锅。她能够利用这一点来提升自己在苏格兰的权威地位。因此，阿兰被迫接受她同自己一起进入枢密院和议会。而这意味着吉斯的玛丽不必再像苏格兰女性那样在幕后以传统方式行事。她直接掌握了权力杠杆，因此她处于推行其梦想政策的绝佳位置，那就是将女儿直接嫁入法国王室。这显然是重续苏格兰与法国旧同盟的绝佳途径，并有可能使苏格兰永久屈从于法国的利益。
But more than that, I mean, you know, she's a geese. She's part of this incredibly ambitious family in France. To marry her daughter into the royal family of France, I mean, that's brilliant. It would be to kill two birds with one stone. So you know, she has everything to play for here. And it works right. Because in 1547, two things happen that play very much into her hands. And the first one is the death of the French king, Francois
但不仅如此，我的意思是，你知道，她是吉斯家族的人。她是法国这个野心勃勃的家族的一员。把她的女儿嫁入法国皇室，我的意思是，这太妙了。这就叫一石二鸟。所以你知道，她在这盘棋里有无限的胜算。而且进展顺利。因为在1547年，发生了两件对她极为有利的事。第一件就是法国国王弗朗索瓦的去世
Premier or Francis the first. So he was the great guy, massive nose, always wrestling Henry the eighth. He was Henry the eighth's big rival. Hanging out with Leonardo da Vinci, all of that. Right. He's dead. And now his son Henry or Henry becomes Henry the second and Henry's a big pals with the Guise family.
也就是弗朗索瓦一世。所以他是个伟岸的人，有着大大的鼻子，总是和亨利八世摔跤。他是亨利八世的主要对手。和达芬奇厮混，诸如此类。对吧。他死了。现在他的儿子亨利成为了亨利二世，而亨利和吉斯家族是好朋友。
His advisors are Guises, Tom. Nice one. Her brothers actually, Mary of Guise's brothers, Francois and Charles. And because of that, basically she has a massive in with the new King of France. Yeah. So Francois and Charles is calledis and Charles. And because of that, basically she has a massive in with the new King of France. Yeah, so Francois and Charles, it's called Francis and Charles. We're very anglophone. So Francis is a military man. He's going to become the Duke of Guise. He's the most brilliant military strategist in France. He's been playing a key part in Francis' wars in Italy that we talked about in the Medici episodes. And his brother, Charles, is the Cardinal of Lorraine,
他的顾问就是吉斯家族，汤姆。说得好。其实是玛丽·德·吉斯的兄弟，弗朗索瓦和查尔斯。正因如此，基本上她和新任法国国王搭上了极大的关系。对。所以弗朗索瓦和查尔斯，被称为弗朗索瓦和查尔斯。我们非常英式发音。所以弗朗索瓦是个军人。他将成为吉斯公爵。他是法国最杰出的军事战略家。他在我们在美第奇剧集中谈到的弗朗索瓦在意大利的战争中发挥了关键作用。他的兄弟查尔斯是洛林枢机主教，
and he's one of a long line of Machiavellian cardinals who are kind of brilliant behind-the-scenes operators, gifted ministers. So Richelieu and Mazarin the next century, very much part of that tradition. And having these two guys, Francis and Charles, at the side of Henry II, Mary of Guise now has a hotline directly to the King. But ironically, this is not the only thing that serves to secure a French royal marriage for the infant Queen of Scots. I say ironically because the key event is actually a really, really disastrous Scottish defeat. So the third great military defeat in Scottish history in the 16th century. But actually what ironically serves to make the match between the infant Queen of Scots
他是长长的马基雅维利式枢机主教谱系中的一员，他们某种程度上是幕后天才操纵者、天赋异禀的大臣。因此，下一个世纪的黎塞留和马萨赞，很大程度上也是这一传统的延续。而有了弗朗索瓦和查尔斯这两个人在亨利二世身边，玛丽·德·吉斯现在就拥有了直通国王的热线。但具有讽刺意味的是，这并不是唯一能确保苏格兰幼女王室联姻的事情。之所以说讽刺，是因为关键事件其实是一场非常非常惨重的苏格兰大败。也就是16世纪苏格兰历史上的第三次重大军事惨败。但实际上，具有讽刺意味的是，这场惨败促成了苏格兰幼女王室联姻
into the Royal French line absolutely a banker is a disastrous Scottish military defeat, the third of the three great military debacles that Scotland suffers in the 16th century. And the context for this is again the rough wooing. So you mentioned Edward Seymour, the brother of Jane Seymour, so the uncle of Henry's son Edward who is now Edward VI, back in London. He's the law protector for Edward VI. And in September 1547, he launches another massive invasion of Scotland. He advances on Edinburgh and the Earl of Arran has raised just about every man that he can
进入法国皇室绝对是板上钉钉的事，这是一场灾难性的苏格兰军事惨败，是苏格兰在16世纪遭受的三次重大军事惨败中的第三次。而其背景依然是残酷求婚。所以你提到了爱德华·西摩，简·西摩的兄弟，也就是亨利现在的儿子爱德华的舅舅，也就是现在的爱德华六世，当时在伦敦。他是爱德华六世的护国公。1547年9月，他对苏格兰发动了又一次大规模入侵。他向爱丁堡推进，阿兰伯爵几乎集结了他所能集结的每一个人
to confront this onslaught. And he masses his forces on the hills above a small hamlet called Pinky, which I think is a great name. And this is probably the largest Scottish army ever assembled. And an English observer seeing it is very intimidated. And he says that the spears of the Scots were as thick as the bristles of a hedgehog. And the result of this exceptional Scottish effort is utter defeat. Aaron runs away, he flees scant with honour, as the description has it, and behind him
来对抗这场猛烈的进攻。他将军队集结在平基这个小村庄上方的山丘上，我觉得这是一个很棒的名字。这可能是苏格兰集结过的最大军队。一位英国观察员看到后感到非常震惊，他说苏格兰人的长矛像刺猬的刚毛一样密集。而这次苏格兰不同寻常的努力带来的结果却是彻底的惨败。阿兰逃跑了，正如描述所说，他狼狈逃窜，而在他身后
he leaves 10,000 dead Scots on the battlefield. And Mary of Gies is so panicked by the news of this debacle that for the first time she worries that Stirling Castle will not be able to hold out. And so she flees with her baby daughter westwards to a remote priory, the Priory of Inchmahome, some 80 miles west of the battlefield of Pinkie, and set on an island in a lock. And just to give a taster of what is to come, this is not the first island in a lock that Mary, Queen of Scots will find herself on. How tantalising.
他在战场上留下了10,000名苏格兰死尸。玛丽·德·吉斯被这场惨败的消息吓得惊慌失措，她第一次担心斯特灵城堡将无法坚守。于是她带着幼小的女儿向西逃到一个偏远的修道院——英奇马霍姆修道院，距离平基战场以西约80英里，坐落在一个湖泊的岛屿上。为了让大家品尝一下即将发生的事情，这并不是苏格兰女王玛丽将发现自己所在的湖中第一个岛屿。多么诱人。
Something to look forward to. What an exciting thought. So basically because the Scots have had this massive debark and they've shamed themselves on the battlefield, they now have to leap into bed with the French. They don't want to be subordinate to England. They have to be subordinate to anybody. They'd rather be with the French.
真是一个值得期待的激动人心的想法。所以基本上，因为苏格兰人经历了这场巨大的惨败，并在战场上蒙羞，他们现在不得不扑向法国人的怀抱。他们不想臣服于英格兰。他们必须臣服于任何人。他们宁愿和法国人在一起。
And Henri, Henry II, the King of France, thinks, brilliant, this is my chance. I can now get in bed with the Scots and probably marry this girl. Yeah. And he acts very, very rapidly because the situation is actually quite dangerous because should the English get hold of Mary Queen of Scots, it's game over for everybody. So what Henry does is he sends a massive expeditionary force. It lands in Leith.
而亨利，也就是亨利二世，法国国王，觉得太棒了，这是我的机会。我现在可以和苏格兰人睡在一起了，而且很可能会娶这个女孩。对。他行动非常非常迅速，因为局势实际上相当危险，如果英国人抓住了苏格兰女王玛丽，对所有人来说就全剧终了。所以亨利采取的行动是派遣了一支庞大的远征军。它在利斯登陆。
So the port that serves Edinburgh in June 1458, 130 ships, 5,500 infantry, 1,000 cavalry, and they basically roll the English back, the English are forced back towards Berwick. The French have a meeting with the Earl of Arran at a nunnery in a small town called Havington, which is about 20 miles east of Edinburgh, and here they sign a treaty. It's agreed that the Earl of Arran at a nunnery in a small town called Havington, which is about 20 miles east of Edinburgh. And here they sign a treaty and it's agreed that the Earl of Arran will become a Duke of France. So he becomes the Duke of Châtel-l'Erore. And it is also agreed more significantly that Mary, Queen of Scots, who at this point is still only five and a half will marry the eldest son of Henry the second, the Dauphin Francis.
也就是服务于爱丁堡的港口，在1458年6月，130艘船，5500名步兵，1000名骑兵，他们基本上把英国人赶了回去，英国人被迫退回伯威克。法国人在距离爱丁堡以东约20英里的小镇哈丁顿的一座修女院与阿兰伯爵会面，在这里他们签署了一项条约。双方同意阿兰伯爵在距离爱丁堡以东约20英里的小镇哈丁顿的一座修女院与阿兰伯爵会面。在这里他们签署了一项条约，并且商定阿兰伯爵将成为法国公爵。因此他成为了沙泰勒罗公爵。更有意义的是，双方还商定，此时年仅五岁半的苏格兰女王玛丽将嫁给亨利二世的长子，王太子弗朗索瓦。
And so as a result of this, the Queen of Scots is destined to become the Queen as well of France and she is shipped off to France very, very rapidly. So the next month, the 29th of July, she boards the ship that will take her to France. She leaves the great fortress of Dumbarton on the Clyde and the ship she boards is the Royal Galley, the galley of the King of France himself that the King has sent to Scotland, this particular mark of honour to Mary. And her escort is the fleet that had sailed to Leith and has now sailed round the northern coast of Scotland and back down to the Clyde. And all the French crews are very impressed by the Queen of Scots.
因此，作为这一切的结果，苏格兰女王注定也将成为法国女王，并且她非常非常迅速地被送往法国。所以在下一个月，即7月29日，她登上了将带她去法国的船。她离开了克莱德河畔的伟大要塞邓巴顿，她登上的船是皇家大帆船，也就是国王派往苏格兰的法国国王本人的大帆船，这是对玛丽的特殊荣誉标志。而她的护航舰队正是曾航行到利斯，现在又绕过苏格兰北部海岸驶回克莱德河的舰队。所有的法国船员都对苏格兰女王印象深刻。
They find her very pretty, very charming, very poised. You know, she's an adorable little muppet, basically. I mean, how poised can you be at five years old? Very apparently. I'm very sceptical of this, Tom. I think five-year-olds by by and large, are not poised. She is simultaneously poised and charming, and these are aspects of her character that will run throughout her life.
他们觉得她非常漂亮，非常迷人，非常有风度。你知道，她基本上是一个可爱的小布偶。我的意思是，你在五岁时能有多大风度？显然很大。我对这一点非常怀疑，汤姆。我认为五岁的孩子大体上是没有风度的。她既有风度又迷人，而这些性格特点将贯穿她的一生。
I know you love Mary Queen of Scots. I absolutely do believe it. You've drunk the iron brew, I think it's fair to say, Tom. Well, we will see. But just to say, they're actually held up for a week because there are storms. I mean, storms in the Scottish summer, who's heard the like. But but very impressively again, Dominic, Mary doesn't fall seasick. Oh, amazing. How remarkable that all these French sailors used to life at sea do fall seasick, but this
我知道你爱苏格兰女王玛丽。我绝对相信这一点。汤姆，我想公平地说，你已经喝了铁酿汽水（意为深信不疑）。好吧，我们会拭目以待。但只要说一句，他们实际上因为暴风雨被耽搁了一个星期。我的意思是，苏格兰夏天的暴风雨，谁听说过这种事。但是多米尼克，再次让人印象深刻的是，玛丽并没有晕船。哦，太惊人了。多么了不起啊，所有这些习惯了海上生活的法国水手都晕船了，而这个
five year old girl doesn't. I absolutely believe you. It's not the French sailors. It's her retainers. And we know that because they wrote about it later in life. Anyway, so eventually they sail off and they're rounding Cornwall again. There's a massive storm. The rudder of the galley gets smashed.
五岁的小女孩却没有。我绝对相信你。不是法国水手。是她的随从。我们知道这一点是因为他们在晚年的著作中写到了。无论如何，最终他们扬帆起航，正绕过康沃尔。又是一场大风暴。大帆船的舵被撞碎了。
She single-handedly sails the ship to France. No, again, poise, I think is the word. Not a sign of fear, perfectly calm, incredibly admirable. Well, I mean, you've got a report here. Yeah, so they finally land. They make land on French soil on the 13th of August, 1548. And Dominic, you've been skeptical, but do you want to know what one of the commanders of the French fleet said about her? No, I don't. But you're going to read it anyway. I absolutely am,
她单枪匹马把船开到了法国。不，再次强调，我想这个词是风度。没有一丝恐惧，非常镇定，令人难以置信的钦佩。好吧，我的意思是，你这里有一篇报道。是的，所以他们最终登陆了。他们于1548年8月13日踏上了法国国土，多米尼克，你一直持怀疑态度，但你想知道法国舰队的一位指挥官对她说了什么吗？不，我不想。但你无论如何都要读。我绝对会，
because I think the listeners want to know. So this French commander said, she, Mary, is one of the most perfect creatures that ever was seen. Such a one as from this very young age with its wondrous and estimable beginnings, has raised such expectations that it is not possible to hope for more from a princess on this earth." So I don't think you can argue with that. Well, Elizabeth I will have something to say about that, Tom. And if listeners want to find out how Mary measures up to these gushing previews, how she gets on in France, why she ends up going back to Scotland and all of the extraordinary melodramatic details of the rest of her life. The explosions, murders, all kinds
因为我认为听众想知道。所以这位法国指挥官说，她，玛丽，是所见过的最完美的生物之一。这样一个从极小的年纪起就带着奇妙而令人尊崇的开端，激起了如此高的期望，以至于不可能对尘世的一位公主抱有更多希望。所以我想你无法反驳这一点。好吧，伊丽莎白一世对此会有话要说，汤姆。如果听众想知道玛丽与这些夸张的预告相比表现如何，她在法国过得怎么样，她为什么最终回到苏格兰，以及她余生所有非凡的戏剧性细节。那些爆炸、谋杀、各种
of plots and conspiracies. Just an amazing, amazing story. So the next episode is coming in a couple of days, but you can get all five remaining episodes of this epic series by signing up to the rest is history club at the rest is history.com. And on that Scottish bombshell. Goodbye. Bye bye. I'm David Oleshoge. And I'm Sarah Churchwell.
阴谋诡计。这真是一个令人惊叹的故事。所以下一集将在几天后播出，但你可以通过在 the rest is history.com 注册加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部，获得这个史诗系列的所有剩余五集。带着这个苏格兰式的重磅消息。再见。再见。我是大卫·奥卢索加。我是萨拉·丘奇韦尔。
Together we're the hosts of Journey Through Time, where we explore the darkest depths of history through the eyes of the people who live through it. Today we're going to tell you about our new series on the Great Fire of London, one of the great pivotal events of the 17th century, one of the most important events in all of English and British history. It began at a bakery on Pudding Lane and quickly turned into a catastrophe. It consumed 13,000 houses, decimated London and caused 10 billion pounds worth of damage in today's money. It even burned down the iconic St. Paul's Cathedral.
我们共同主持《穿越时空之旅》，在这里，我们通过亲历者的视角探索历史最黑暗的深处。今天我们要向大家讲述我们关于伦敦大火的新系列节目，这是17世纪重大的关键事件之一，也是整个英国和不列颠历史中最重要事件之一。它始于布丁巷的一家面包店，并迅速演变成一场灾难。它吞噬了13,000栋房屋，满目疮痍了伦敦，以今天的货币计算，造成了100亿英镑的损失。它甚至烧毁了标志性的圣保罗大教堂。
The city was already devastated by the Great Plague, but rumors of foreign invasion led mobs to attack innocent foreigners on the streets. In this episode, we'll explore the chilling consequences of rumors of fake news of xenophobia, problems that clearly are not unique to today. From desperate attempts to save their homes and belongings, to the struggle to assign blame which turned deadly. This is the story of the fire as it was lived through by the people on the ground and the lasting impacts it left on the city.
这座城市已经饱受大瘟疫的摧残，但关于外国入侵的谣言导致暴徒在街头袭击无辜的外国人。在本集中，我们将探讨虚假新闻和仇外心理谣言带来的令人不寒而栗的后果，这些问题显然并非当今所独有。从拼命拯救家园和财物的尝试，到归咎责任演变成致命冲突的挣扎。这就是地面上的人们所经历的火灾故事，以及它对这座城市留下的持久影响。
We've got a short clip at the end of this episode. It's David Olusoga from Journey Through Time. Here's that clip that we mentioned earlier. If you look at all of the accounts of the fire at this point, as we get to the end of Sunday the second, the first day, this fire is not behaving in any way the way fires traditionally did in London. And there is some people who've argued that it was becoming a firestorm, that the heat and the wind and the movement of air caused by the fire was feeding it, was becoming self-sustaining as it were. John Evelyn, who's a great writer and a diarist of this moment, he talks about the
在本集结束时我们有一段简短的剪辑。那是来自《穿越时空之旅》的大卫·奥卢索加。这就是我们刚才提到的那个剪辑。如果你看看所有关于此时火灾的记载，当我们到达周日2月（应为周日2日）也就是第一天的结束时，这场火灾的表现与伦敦传统火灾的方式完全不同。有些人认为它正在变成一场风暴，火灾产生的热量、风和空气流动正在为其提供燃料，可以说它正在变得自我维持。约翰·埃夫林，他是那一时期伟大的作家和日记作家，他谈到了
sound of the fire. He said it was like thousands of chariots driving over cobblestones. There are descriptions in Peeps and elsewhere of this great arc of fire in the sky. I mean, imagine that everything around you is colored by the flames, yellows and oranges, and above you is this thick black smoke. This is a city you know, these are streets you walk, this is a place that's deeply familiar to you and it looks completely otherworldly. It looks like another, like a sort of landscape
火的声音。他说那就像数千辆战车驶过鹅卵石路面。佩皮斯和其他人的著作中都有对天空中巨大火弧的描述。我的意思是，想象一下你周围的一切都被火焰染上了颜色，黄色和橙色，而你头顶上方是浓密的黑烟。这是一座你熟知的城市，这些是你走过的街道，这是一个对你而言极其熟悉的地方，但它看起来完全不属于这个世界。它看起来像另一个，像某种景观
you've never seen before. People describe the fire almost as if it's supernatural. If you wanna hear the full episode, listen to Journey Through Time wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你从未见过的景观。人们形容这场火灾几乎就像是超自然的。如果你想听完整的一集，请在任何你获取播客的地方收听《穿越时空之旅》。本集目前还没有评论。点击字幕中的任何句子即可发表评论。